احنا بقايا بقايا انسان احنا ما فيش حياه
حياتنا
انعدمت جرحانه بموتوا بالبطيء بيوتنا راحت
اطفالنا
راحت ما ضلش فينا شي ماظل فينا
حي احنا تدمرنا فعليا يعني المرحله اللي
بصل لها مرحله قاسيه جدا جدا جدا جدا اسوا
مما
تتخيل وضع الناس يرثى له يرثى له بمعنى
كلمه يرتى له ما عرفنا ايش نسوي ما عرفنا
ما طلع بادينا شيء يعني انا بطلب من
الجرحه
يسامحونا على قله امكانياتنا وم عارفين
ايش نعملهم بتمنى يجي اسعافات تنسق نطلع
الجرحه على مصر على اي دوله بالعالم المهم
يطلعوهم منها وموتوا في البطيء اللي بنقدر
ننقذ حياته يا ريت ما تتاخروا علينا يا
ريت ما تتاخروا علينا بتمنى من الصحافه
توصل هذه الرساله لكل العالم وتشوف وضع
الجرحه وتشوف وضع الناس اللي بتموت
بالبطيء ويا ريت هذه الرساله تصل لكل
العالم